The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we were doing
velocities and accelerations.
We came up with-- I guess I
ought to continue to remind us.
We're talking about
velocities and accelerations
of a point with respect to
another point, to which we've
attached-- I'll make
this point here--
a reference frame, x
prime, y prime, z prime.
And there's a vector that
goes between these two
and a vector that goes there
so that we can say r of B
with respect to O, my
inertial frame, is r of A
with respect to O plus
r of B with respect
to A. These are all vectors.
And then from these, we derive
velocities and acceleration
formulas.
And so we've come up with a
couple of very handy formulas.
The velocity formula, velocity
of B with respect to O,
is the velocity
of A with respect
to O plus you have to take
a time derivative of this.
And so I'm going to give you
just the general expression
here just as a brief reminder.
It's the derivative
of B with respect
to A as seen in the Axyz frame
plus omega with respect to O
cross rBA.
These are all vectors.
So that's the velocity
formula, remember?
This is if you're in
the frame rotating
and translating with
it, this is the change
of length of the vector.
And this, then, is the
contribution to the velocity
that you see in the fixed frame
that comes from the rotation.
And we then got into
polar coordinates.
And we found out that if
you use polar coordinates,
then you can express
this as the velocity of A
with respect to O
plus r dot r hat.
And I should really say
cylindrical coordinates,
z dot k hat plus r
theta dot theta hat.
So that's exactly
the same thing.
This is full 3D vector notation.
This is a special case of
a coordinate system which
we call polar coordinates.
And we came up with another
formula for accelerations,
the full 3D vector version
of that, A with respect
to O plus-- this is
the acceleration of B
with respect to A, but as
seen in the Axyz frame.
2 omega cross-- and
this is v, the velocity,
as seen in the xyz frame.
So these things, this is no
contribution from acceleration.
This is no contribution
from acceleration.
Plus omega naught cross
rBA plus omega cross
omega cross rBA-- all vectors.
This is a movement of the
frame, the acceleration of it
with respect to this.
This is pure translation.
This is the acceleration
of the dog on the merry go
round with respect to the center
of the coordinate system there.
It does not involve rotation.
This is this term
that we call Coriolis.
This is a term we call Euler.
This is the angular speed up
of the system, the angular
acceleration.
And this is centripetal.
And if you do these,
if you want to go
to cylindrical coordinates--
and what we're going to do next
is just do some
applications here.
The acceleration of B with
respect to O and cylindrical
coordinates-- it's
a translation piece.
Plus now in cylindrical,
it's useful to group these.
So I'm going to put together
this term and this term.
Because they're both
in the r hat direction.
And I'm going to put
together these two terms.
Because they're both in
the theta hat direction.
And I need a z double dot
k, because it's cylindrical.
And then I have the
theta hat piece,
r theta double dot plus 2r
dot theta dot theta hat.
This is the same thing as this.
Except this is expressed
in cylindrical coordinates.
And cylindrical coordinates
are particularly
good for doing the kind of
problems that are mostly
done at the level of this
course, which we call planar
motion problems, confined
to an x, y plane,
and confined to single
axis rotation in z.
This is a coordinate system
that's ideally suited
to do problems like that.
And that's why we use it.
So now let's do some examples.
This is really
quite a powerful--
now that you have
these two equations,
you can do a lot of
kinematics and dynamics.
So we started last time
right at the very end.
I said, OK, let's do this
problem really quickly, right?
Constant rotation
rate, constant radius,
no angular
acceleration, no change
in length of the thing--
pretty simple problem.
And we zipped it
off really fast.
And I wanted to start there,
do that really quickly.
So this is my case one.
It's my ball on the string.
Here's point A. Here's point
B. Here's the theta hat
direction, r hat direction.
And it has some
constant length R here.
So r dot r double dot are 0.
There's no also z, z dot, z
double dot, no z motion at all.
Those are all 0.
Theta dot is a constant.
I'll call it cap omega in the k
hat direction, right hand rule.
Theta double dot is 0.
So the easy way to
use these formulas
is you just start
knocking out all the terms
that you don't need.
But let's, just to give you
a little quick review of how
to use these things,
use the vector full
3D version of the velocity
equation for a second.
The full 3D version
says the velocity of A
with respect to O, what's
that in this problem?
That's the translating term.
So I was standing still,
not going anywhere.
But if I were walking along,
I'd still spin that thing.
OK, so this problem,
this term is 0.
This problem, r
dot-- let's go here.
This is the rate of
change of the length
of the string in the coordinate
system of the string walking
along.
So what's r dot?
OK, so that term is 0.
And omega cross rBA-- well, r is
in the R hat, capital R R hat,
cross with omega k.
k cross R is-- k cross of R hat?
STUDENT: Theta.
PROFESSOR: Theta hat.
So we get our familiar--
this first term is 0.
The second term is 0.
The third term, we
just get our R omega
in the theta hat direction.
We know that to be true.
The point I'm just
trying to make here
is you can always just fall
back and use the vector formula,
full 3D formulas of both.
Just plug it in, and
everything will just drop out.
You can also then go to the
cylindrical coordinate terms
when you happen to
have it all expressed
in coordinates of that kind
to make it simpler for you.
OK, so now let's quickly
then do the acceleration of B
with respect to O. And let's
use the formulation already
in cylindrical coordinates.
What's A with respect to O?
0.
What's r double dot?
How about the r theta dot
squared term, 0 or not?
Nope.
Let's go on-- z double dot?
STUDENT: 0.
PROFESSOR: r theta double dot?
PROFESSOR: r dot theta dot?
STUDENT: 0
PROFESSOR: OK, we only
end up with one term.
Actually, I'm going to keep
this one for a second-- A
with respect to O minus.
And we came up with our R
theta dot squared r hat term.
I leave this in here because
I actually don't have to say.
If I wanted now to
do this problem,
if I asked you to do a
problem where I'm doing this,
and I start accelerating,
do you know how to do it?
There's the answer--
still there, right?
All right, let's do a
quick free body diagram.
Here's our mass, my master
coordinate system out here.
Let's draw-- let's say it's
right here at 90 degrees.
What are the external forces
on the mass in this problem?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So there's
tension in the string, right?
OK, so now this is a really
trivially simple problem.
So the emphasize here
is on the concept.
So now when you're asked to come
up with an equation of motion
or compute the forces on a
mass, use Newton's second law,
F equals mass
times acceleration.
You now have the complete
3D vector formulation
for acceleration of a particle
in a translating rotating
coordinate system.
That's all you need to
compute accelerations for lots
and lots of difficult problems.
And so if you can write
down the acceleration,
you say it's equal to what?
Mass-- if you multiply mass
times that acceleration,
what's that equal to?
STUDENT: The force.
PROFESSOR: The forces that
must be acting on the system.
And that's the point here.
So now I want to know the forces
on the system, the summation
of the external forces.
And then these are vectors.
And you can do them
component by component.
Some of the external forces
in the r hat direction
must be equal to the
mass-- in this case, just
a particle-- times the
acceleration of that particle.
And in this problem,
then that would
be the mass times the
acceleration of A with respect
to O minus R theta
dot squared r hat.
And this would have to be the
r hat component of this thing.
I said I just want
the R component.
I'd have to figure out
if I was running along,
if I had it in the same
direction as r hat.
What part of that acceleration
is in that direction?
That would come here.
If there's 0, you
just make it 0.
So let's just let
the acceleration of A
with respect to O be 0.
Then that says the sum of
the forces in the r direction
is equal to the mass minus
mR theta dot squared.
And if we were to draw
a free body diagram,
we would find out
that, ahh, there
must be a tension on
the string pulling
in on the mass
sufficient to give it
the acceleration
that you've computed.
So every problem,
when you're asked
to compute the force,
or the next step up,
find the equation of motion,
the equation of motion
is just writing this thing out.
OK, now I want to move on to
a more interesting problem.
All right, I'm going
to do this problem.
So it's a hollow tube.
And we're going to look at
things like, I put a ping pong
ball in it.
And if I swing this tube
around, the ping pong ball
is going to come out.
OK, there must be some
forces on that thing
to cause it to come out.
There must be some
accelerations on them.
And so I could
conceivably have an R,
a theta double dot acceleration.
It certainly is going to have
theta dot rotation rates.
The ball is allowed to move.
So there can be nonzero
r dots, r double dots--
a lot going on inside of
this simple little tube.
So that's what I
want to figure out.
Let's see if we can come up
with a model for this problem.
So here's my z-axis.
I have a rotation around it,
some theta dot k hat direction.
Here's my tube.
It's rotating around.
So this is sort of a side
view, your view of the tube.
Here's that ping
pong ball in there.
And I'm going to
idealize that ping pong
ball for a minute, a little
more general problem.
Let's say I have kind of a
nut on this thing, a disk,
something hanging
onto the outside.
And I can control
the rate, the speed
at which this thing goes out.
The ping pong
ball, this is going
to be an application of this.
But I want to be able to
do several other versions,
like make the speed
constant for a second.
OK, and looking
down on this thing,
top view, here's
our inertial frame,
maybe out here like this.
Here's my mass.
So in polar coordinates,
here's your theta.
The r is this.
This is your r hat.
This is your theta
hat directions.
I'm going to let the velocity
of A with respect to O be 0,
so there's no translational
of this system.
And z, z dot, z double
dot, those are all 0.
So nothing's happening
in the z direction.
So I want to first
compute the velocity of B
with respect to O.
And you ought to be able to
do that sort of by inspection.
It comes only from-- oh,
I haven't told you enough.
What do I want to make
happen in this problem?
I want to let r dot--
it's going to be some vr,
and it's constant.
I'm not going to go quite to
my ping pong shooter here yet.
I'm going to do a slightly
simpler problem first.
So this is a constant.
That means r double dot is 0.
So this thing is
just-- let's say
you had threads on this
thing, and it's a screw,
and it's just moving its
way out at a constant rate.
And I'm going to have constant
angular, so theta dot.
I'll call that cap omega k hat.
So the angular rate
is also constant.
All right, if that's the
case, can you tell me,
what's v of B with respect
to my fixed frame O?
Well, any time you're not sure,
you go back to this formula,
throw out terms.
There's no z dot term.
This is constant.
This is 0, 0, 0.
You have this term.
It's some vr in the
r hat direction.
You have this term, wherever it
happens to be in the theta hat
direction.
r dot in the r hat
direction plus r theta
dot in the theta
hat direction-- OK,
we need acceleration
next, B with respect to O.
And now you can crank
through the terms again.
This time, the first term is 0.
The second term is 0,
because it's constant.
The third term is
definitely not 0.
The fourth term is 0.
Fifth term?
0.
This term?
Not 0.
Let me just write them.
So you get a minus r theta
dot squared r hat-- that's
the radial direction term--
plus 2r dot theta dot theta hat.
That's the accelerations.
So you have an acceleration
now in the r hat direction
and in the theta hat direction.
If there's acceleration
to those directions,
there must be forces.
Newton's second law now
says, again, the force
is the mass times acceleration.
And this is a vector.
This is a vector.
It has two components.
And the nice thing about these
Newton's laws and vectors
is you can break the problems
down into their vector
components and treat
the r direction
as one equation of
motion, and the theta
direction as a separate one.
So we might want to draw
a free body diagram.
Here's this block
working its way out.
We know that there's
probably some axial force.
I'm just going to
call it T. And there's
some other unknown force here
in the theta hat direction.
So this is my theta hat.
I've drawn this just
intentionally in the positive r
hat direction.
The sign that comes
out will tell us
which direction it really
is if you're not certain.
Just draw it positive, in
the positive r hat direction.
And that's your
free body diagram.
If I wanted to put gravity
in there, I might have.
But we're doing this in
the horizontal plane.
Gravity is in and out this way.
It's in the z direction.
And we know it's constrained,
can't move. z double dot is 0.
So there's certainly a support
force that picks up the weight.
But this is in our
horizontal plane.
There's your free body diagram.
And we can write two equations
to solve for these things.
So the sum of the forces in
the r hat direction is T.
And that must be equal to the
mass times the acceleration
in the r, minus mr theta dot
squared in the r hat direction.
Sure enough, the tension
has to pull inwards
in the minus r hat direction.
And that's the full result.
STUDENT: Where are the
T and F forces exactly?
PROFESSOR: Where are they?
OK, so I'm going to bring
the ball to the outside
where you can see it.
This thing is going in this
direction, horizontal plane, x,
y plane.
It's moving its fixed rate out.
So its speed when
it's in here is r
over 2 omega in that direction.
And the speed when it's out here
is r omega in that direction.
So clearly it's
picking up speed.
If it's picking up speed, is
it picking up kinetic energy?
Is there work being
done on it somehow
to build up that energy?
So there must be
some forces at play.
So there's a normal
force from the wall
of this thing pushing this
ball sideways to speed it up,
for sure.
That's one force.
And the other force is because
I'm not allowing this thing
just to go freely out.
I'm constraining it
to constant speed out.
It would really like to
go a lot faster than that.
So what's holding it back?
At any instance in time, it
has centripetal acceleration.
And what's making
it go in the circle
is a force that
is-- in this case,
if that were a nut with threads,
in the threads are applying
to the nut to keep
it from running away.
STUDENT: In that
free body diagram,
F, doesn't F act similar
between theta and r hat?
And then there's
like a component
of theta hat in there?
PROFESSOR: Well,
I've broken down.
I've chosen.
The total force
acting on this thing
is some combination of a
force in that direction
and a combination in
the axial direction.
So it has some net direction
that's neither this nor that.
STUDENT: From that equation,
it looks like what you drew,
F has an r hat component.
PROFESSOR: So this
thing is rotating
about some center over here.
So this is theta dot.
Theta is going in this
direction, theta dot.
And we've chosen a coordinate
system that has unit vectors r
hat and theta hat.
And so it makes sense.
We can express the
acceleration in terms
of those two components.
It makes sense to express the
forces in the same direction.
So I've just arbitrarily said,
I have some unknown force
that's in this direction.
And I have another unknown
force in that direction.
Then I'm saying, they
account for all forces
in this direction,
whatever their source.
That tells me that the
sum of the external forces
in the theta hat direction in
this case is this unknown F.
But I know from
Newton that that's
got to be equal to the
mass times the acceleration
in that direction.
In this case, then, that is
2mr dot theta dot theta hat.
So just from
applying the equation
and applying
Newton's second law,
I can find out what
that force must be.
It would've been a
lot more work if I
had drawn it in some arbitrary
in between direction.
Because then I'd have to break
it down into its compounds
to write this.
So I've made it as easy
as possible for myself.
So there's a force like this.
And there is another
force like that.
This one is caused by the
centripetal acceleration.
Or this force causes the
In order to make something
go in a circular path,
you have to exert a force on it.
That's the force.
In order to accelerate
something angularly,
you have to apply a force.
That comes from the Euler term.
And this is a curious term.
This is the Coriolis term.
So where does it come from?
That's the crux of
the matter here.
Where does it come from?
So part of the reading that you
need to do now is Chapter 15.
Chapter 15, most of it is
going to be complete review.
It just says the conservation
of a linear momentum, impulse
and momentum.
But it also gets into
angular momentum.
So we're going to talk quite
a lot about angular momentum.
And I want to do a very brief
little review right now so
that it applies to this problem.
So we've come up
with an expression
that the force in
the theta direction
here comes-- there's got to
be that, 2mr dot theta dot.
So here's my point O,
and A for that matter.
But looking down on
our problem, here's
my mass at some instant in time.
My rotation rate is theta dot--
or actually it's constant.
So it's k hat like
that, cap omega k hat.
This is my r hat
direction, theta hat.
Now, I'm going to treat
this as a particle.
Not long-- we're going to be
talking about the dynamics
of rigid bodies.
We're just doing
particles for the moment.
We think of them
just as point masses
and don't deal with
their finite extent.
So we're still thinking
of this as a particle.
And I'm going to write down
the definition of the angular
momentum of a particle.
This is B out here with respect
to my fixed frame here at O.
And I'm going to use a
lowercase h to describe
angular momentum of particles.
And I'll use capital H
to describe the angular
momentum of rigid bodies.
So this is a particle,
the definition
of the angular momentum
of a particle with respect
to a fixed point.
We're going to
come back to that.
That'll turn out to
have some significance.
The definition of this is
it's RBO, the position vector,
crossed with the linear momentum
evaluated in the fixed frame.
So that's the definition
of angular momentum, which
is you have linear
momentum, and it's
the cross product with the
position vector out to it.
So in this case, the
RBO is capital R R hat.
Well, it's not-- this
varies, excuse me.
So I'm not going to use--
this I use as a constant.
I better keep it
as the variable.
Pardon that, so it's r,
whatever the local position is,
in the r hat direction crossed
with the linear momentum.
What's the linear
momentum of that particle?
Mass times velocity.
What's the velocity?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Theta dot-- where
did we write it up here?
Someplace-- the total velocity
is r dot r hat plus r theta
dot theta hat.
And we need a mass in here.
So mass times velocity
would be the momentum.
And we need the cross
products of those.
r hat cross r hat, you
get nothing from that.
And r hat cross theta
hat-- positive or negative?
Positive k, right?
So this becomes mr squared theta
dot in the k hat direction.
And this one is a constant.
We'll write this as cap omega.
So this is my angular momentum
of my particle with respect
to this fixed reference frame.
And so one final
step that you know
from your previous
physics is-- how's torque
related to angular momentum?
Take a guess.
What do you remember?
Time derivative-- so
d by dt of hBO here.
The time rate of
change of this vector
is the torque with respect to
this point, with respect to O.
So what are constants
in this thing?
We don't have to deal
with their derivatives.
k hat is-- does the direction
of the angular momentum change?
It's upwards.
The derivative of k,
the unit vector k,
does it change in this problem?
No, so its time derivative is 0.
Its time derivative is 0.
The m time derivative is 0.
The only thing you have
to take the derivative of
is r, so 2rr dot.
So the torque is
2mrr dot cap omega.
And it's all in the k direction.
And that had better be
rBO cross F. Torque comes
as a force times a
moment arm, right?
And we computed here a force
in the theta direction.
So what would give us a
torque in the k direction?
An r cross a theta.
r hat cross theta
hat gives you a k.
r cross-- and this force,
the part of the force.
We have two forces,
one in the r direction
and one in the theta direction.
The cross product, this term up
here, the T gives you nothing,
r cross r hat cross r hat.
So the only force that matters
here is this Coriolis one.
And so that force is
2mr dot theta dot.
And we have the r cross.
We know this comes out
in the k direction.
And we get an r in here when
we compute this product.
And this, to me, looks
an awful lot like this.
Except I missed an r squared.
How did I do that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh no,
it's not r squared.
It started off over here as
the angular momentum has an r
squared, took the derivative.
It dropped down to 2rr dot.
And that's right.
So the Coriolis
force, what's it got
to do with the angular momentum?
That's kind of the point
of the exercise here.
In order for this ping pong
ball to be accelerated,
as it goes slowly out this
tube, the angular momentum
is increasing.
In order to change angular
momentum with time,
you have to apply a torque.
The torque that
you have to apply
is 2mrr dot in the k direction.
And that is r cross
the Coriolis force.
So the Coriolis
force, in this case,
is the force that's necessary
to increase the angular
momentum of a system.
That's very often
the reason-- that's
what Coriolis force is about.
So when you shoot an
artillery piece on the Earth,
you've got that projectile
going out there.
It has angular momentum
with respect to the Earth.
And you'll find out that
this little term pops up.
And in fact, the projectile
doesn't go straight.
It curves.
There's lots of things that
because of conservation
of angular momentum, you end
up with this term popping up.
In this case, angular
momentum is not conserved.
It's increasing.
So you have this force
to make it happen.
Any questions about this?
You're going to
use this one a lot.
work with it a lot.
So anytime you see changes
in angular momentum happening
in a problem, in these
problems with circular motion,
velocities of parts
increasing in radius,
you'll almost always
see this term pop up.
Any time you see these
changes in angular momentum,
you'll often see
the Coriolis term.
All right, now we're going to
do another interesting problem--
simple but interesting.
And that is really to go--
let's go do this problem
where the thing is really
allowed to come freely out.
All right, you ready
to defend yourself?
A little short stick is pretty
effective at throwing candy.
You got your safety glasses on?
You want me to see if
I can get one up there?
Aww, also, I obviously
haven't practiced this.
All right, last one.
Actually, there's two more.
What makes this work?
Let's do this problem.
So let's look at
our candy shooter.
So I'm whipping
this thing around.
Candy is coming out of here.
It's at B.
Again, I get no z, not
mess with the z part.
The z part is trivial
to usually deal with.
Because it's
totally independent,
just separate equations.
It doesn't complicate
things much at all,
even when you have z.
Now, in this case, the
velocity-- and here's
my O frame here.
The velocity B
with respect to O,
well, now it's got--
I'm not going to move.
I'm standing still when I do it.
So the first term is 0.
It's got an r term, r dot
in the r hat direction.
And it has an r theta
dot theta hat term.
And these can now--
this might be changing.
This might have a time
derivative, r double dot.
It certainly does.
It's accelerating
coming out of that tube.
And my theta, angular motion,
it can be accelerating, too.
So we're going to have
to deal with those.
I need to know
the accelerations.
Now, I haven't
emphasized it till now,
but I find it conceptually
useful to-- when
you work with polar
coordinates, you
can have this
ability to aggregate
the terms in these two
component directions.
So you have this.
All the r terms go together.
And we've let the
z double dot term--
it's just separate by itself.
It drops out easily.
And you have the theta hat term.
And that's the r theta double
dot plus 2r dot theta dot.
And these are in the
theta hat direction.
There's your Coriolis term,
your Euler acceleration
term, centripetal term.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, I
don't know if I ought
to tell you secrets about me.
Because it's going to give
you an advantage on the quiz.
But I've almost
never, ever been known
to ask a question
that says, "derive."
But I'll sure ask you
concept questions.
I really want you to
understand the principles.
I don't get real hung
up on having you do
the grungy grind it out things.
Do I want you to
remember the formula
for how to take the derivative
of a vector in rotating frame?
Yeah, that's where
these have come from.
You had better remember this.
These two formulas, the
velocity formula and this,
the acceleration formula,
are just core to this course.
Now, the way quizzes
are done-- first quiz,
you come in, one sheet of paper.
What had better
be on your paper?
OK?
And second quiz, two
sheets, final, three sheets,
that kind of thing.
But conceptually, you've
got forces in the r,
forces in the z,
accelerations in r theta
and z, forces r theta and z.
And for these planar
motion problems,
this one is sure easy to use.
So let's think
about this problem.
I'm going to let this
be frictionless just
to make it easy.
All right, so what
possible forces act
on the hunk of candy?
Let's do a free body
diagram of the hunk of candy
coming out of here.
What are the forces?
And let's keep it planar.
We can get gravity into this.
But let's just do it in a plane.
So I'm just going horizontal
and slinging this thing.
Gravity's in the z
direction, and I've
constrained it in the z.
So it's something supporting
the gravity in the tube.
So definitely there's an
mg on this thing downwards.
But it's in the z
direction, and we're not
letting it move in the z.
What about the horizontal,
this direction?
The r-- this is my
r hat direction.
This is my theta hat direction.
Whoops, not either--
theta is going this way.
So I've drawn this
as a side view.
What's the force in
the r hat direction?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, in order
to do the problem,
you have to figure that out.
What are the forces?
What are the source of
forces in the r direction?
Here's the r direction.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Say what?
Come on, you guys.
Somebody be-- yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There are not any.
Is that what you said?
There aren't any.
And why's that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so there's
no forces in the r direction.
So there's no forces
on this thing in the r.
And so then this is a side view.
We could do the top
view looking down.
Top view, you've got your x, y.
You also have your--
here's the ball.
Here's the r hat.
Here's the theta hat.
Now, free body diagram
in the top view--
well, there's some
force here probably.
STUDENT: I was going to
ask that the fact that we
have no forces in the r
hat direction, but we do
have acceleration.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
She's commenting that
we do have accelerations
in the r direction, right?
STUDENT: And we have no force.
PROFESSOR: And no force.
So that's the conundrum
of this problem.
That's the point
So let me continue.
Free body diagram--
I'm looking down on it.
I'm allowing for some force.
It's the normal force that
comes from the pipe exerting
the force on the candy.
And since it's frictionless, it
can only be normal to the pipe.
OK, so there's the free body
diagram in the top view.
So we can write two equations.
We can write three
questions-- this one
equal to 0, this one
in the r hat direction,
this one in the
theta hat direction.
Sum of the forces r hat
direction must be 0.
And we have a mass.
We have an acceleration.
Solve for r double dot.
Remarkable-- there's no
force in the r hat direction.
The position of
the object, the r
coordinate, it has a velocity.
It has an acceleration.
But the total acceleration
in the r hat directions
are actually 0.
The rate of change
of the velocity
of this thing in the radial
direction, r double dot,
is nonzero.
But there are no forces on it.
I have pondered another
way to explain this.
I'm still thinking about it.
And you think about this, too.
How do you explain this
in the absence of forces?
And it's partly
where the concept
comes from of fictitious forces,
that centrifugal force is
a force.
It's not.
It's an acceleration.
This is just saying that--
let's go back to this problem.
In order to make
something go in a circle,
you have to put a
force on it to cause
the centripetal acceleration.
You have to allow the thing
to go out if you're not
forcing it to go in a circle.
You have to allow it to go
out at that rate in order
for there to be no centripetal
accelerations on the object.
Yeah?
STUDENT: So I was going
to say, when you start it,
you push it in the y direction.
So that's a force.
It's not in the r hat,
but it's in the y.
PROFESSOR: To get it started.
STUDENT: Right, and there's
no force opposing it
in that direction [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Does it experience
centripetal acceleration?
So there's no rotation.
Does it experience
centripetal acceleration?
What do you think?
Yeah, because it goes
through curved motion.
At any instance in time
when it's doing that,
there is a radius of curvature.
You can at that instant
in time think of it
as being in a circular path.
And sometimes it's
just really easy
to do these kind of problems
with normal and tangential
coordinates.
So I'm looking down
on the x, y plane.
Gravity is into the Earth.
So I'm looking down
on a vehicle, a car.
And that car, the
guy is kind of drunk.
He's going down
the road like this.
So here's my y.
Here's my x.
And y equals some A sine
2 pi over the wavelength,
2 pi over lambda, times
x at some A sine kx.
And as he drives down--
if you're in a car,
and you're doing that, you get
thrown side to side in the car.
So you are being accelerated.
And so we want to
be able to calculate
the acceleration due to
the fact that you're going
down and doing a curved path.
And we deal with
these things sometimes
with a convenient little
set of coordinates
that are our normal
and tangential unit
vectors, u normal
and u tangential,
at any instant in time.
And we know that if
this is along the path,
at any instant in time
you're right here,
what direction is your velocity?
Just definition of velocity--
tangent to the path, right?
So at any instant in
time, the velocity
has got to be tangent to
the path at that moment.
So velocity, the vector, has
a magnitude and a unit vector
uT here I'll call it, tangent.
That's all there is to it.
And the acceleration
of this thing
is your time derivative of this.
And that's going to give
you a v dot uT hat plus a v.
And now you need a time
derivative of this guy.
But this is a unit
length vector.
You can plug it
into that equation
for the derivative
of a rotating vector
and calculate what
this should be.
You could also just draw it out.
So I'll draw this for you.
How are we doing on time?
I should just be
able to finish this.
Here's my unit vector in
the tangential direction.
As I'm going around
this curve, this
is my tangential direction.
There's some instant
I have a radius.
We call that rho.
And in the little
time, delta t, I
go through an angle
delta theta in delta t.
And this is my uT vector here.
It changes by a little bit.
That's the change in the uT unit
vector in this time, delta t.
And it goes perpendicular.
And it goes in the
positive un direction.
So delta-- what's the easiest
way to write this one?
Delta uT equals some
theta dot delta t-- that's
the angle-- times the length
of the unit vector, 1.
That's the distance
it goes, so 1.
So r omega, 1 theta
dot is the distance
that this unit vector
goes through in delta t.
And the direction it
goes in is u normal hat.
So delta uT over
delta t limit as t
goes to 0, you get theta
dot un, just like before.
So the time derivative
of this unit vector
in the tangential
direction is just theta dot
in the normal direction.
And then from that,
we can very quickly
derive the rest of
this acceleration.
The acceleration then
is that plus this.
We now know an expression
for-- this is my uT dot term.
I'm going to plug that in here.
This then, we need an
expression for v. What's v?
Well, at that instant in
time, it has some radius rho.
It has an angular
velocity theta dot.
So rho theta dot
would be the v here.
So I'm looking for an
expression for vuT dot.
So that's v theta dot un.
But theta dot is v over rho.
v squared-- sorry about
this-- over rho un.
So this guy up here, this
is v dot uT plus v squared--
I'll rewrite it-- over rho un.
So if you're speeding
up, if you're
going from 30 miles an
hour to 40 miles an hour,
that's your tangential.
That's your speed
along the path.
That's this term.
But because you're
going around the curve,
you have an acceleration
of v squared over rho.
You've run into this
before in physics.
This is where it comes from.
This is a centripetal
acceleration like term.
If you replace v
with rho theta dot,
you'd get r theta dot squared.
So you can either put it in
terms of v squared over rho,
or you can put it in terms
of rho theta dot squared.
And rho theta dot squared sounds
a lot like my acceleration term
right here.
So with that simple
little formula,
you can do-- you
need one other thing.
And you just go look
it up in the book.
There is an expression from
calculus for the radius
of curvature of a path.
And it has first and second
derivatives of y with respect
to x.
So you need a dy/dx
and a d2y dx squared.
From a sine function,
you can calculate that.
So you calculate
rho from a formula
that's in the book
for calculating
radius of curvature.
And then you're done, all right?
So see you on Thursday.